Okay. Yeah, I know,
uh, the one of many talents who's brought
as many speakers here and is here today
for us,
Sheryl Sandberg
[inaudible]
see how we improvise.
So it is a great pleasure of women
at Google to welcome Senator Hillary
Clinton's who are stage along
with our CEO, Eric Schmidt,
[inaudible] [inaudible] senator.
Senator
Clinton was elected at United States
senator in 2000 reelected in 2006 making
her the first first lady
to ever hold public office.
She has sponsored and led many bipartisan
efforts on things that are close to
our hearts, computerized medical
records, rural broadband,
broadband access for rural communities,
r, and d and nanotechnology.
She's also led really important efforts
for the country on public education,
modernizing our school's job creation and
importantly universal health coverage.
January of 2007 so just last year on
January 20th she announced the creation of
a presidential exploratory committee
on the Internet. We love that.
I think everyone knows we started the
women at Google series to bring women who
have really made a difference
in the world to Google by far.
Senator Clinton has been
our most requested speaker,
so we are thrilled that she is
here with us today. And as always,
we thank Eric for his support of our
program. Thank you all for being here.
[inaudible]
pretty excited about having you here, Mrs.
Clinton. I'm excited about being here.
The people with the hats are new
employees, so don't be disturbed.
That's why they have their little,
their little name tags on.
They describe what they do and the weird
things they did to get into the car,
into the company. Um, I that in Washington
when, uh, uh, as some of you know,
I worked some with the
President Bill Clinton and,
and the vice president Al
Gore on some Internet work.
And in the context of that they had
a fellow working for them named Ira
Magaziner who became a good friend and is
very, very sharp guy. And one day I was,
and this was in 96 or 97
and I sat down with Ira,
we were having a nice chat and I was
saying how incredibly intelligent the
president was. And he
said she's smarter. And I,
I thought that's pretty amazing.
And so I filed that away.
So the next year I go to Davos and there's
a dinner and Mrs. Clinton shows up.
And then the next morning I go to her
speak her speech and I've not heard her
speak before.
And she talked for an hour
about the purview of the world,
social change, business
policy, international issues,
and she did the speech,
which is a brilliant
speech without any notes,
a feat that I have still
not been able to replicate
the,
I'm still,
I'm still thinking about this.
We're talking about an extraordinary
national leader here on stage at Google
today. Welcome to Google. Thank you.
You very much.
I am absolutely thrilled to be here,
uh,
to have a chance to come
and see for myself, uh,
the best place to work in America.
Number one
place that is really helping
to invent the future. You know,
one of the great things about America
is that we've always been more about the
future then nearly any place
ever in the history of the world.
And probably,
I hope we will always be that.
But part of what it means to envision
the future and help to create it is
figuring out how to work together
to achieve some of those goals.
And what you've done here at Google
and just a very short period of time,
uh, has revolutionized
the way we live. We work,
we think information
that's accessible to us.
And so I'm delighted to not only be here
to have this conversation with Eric,
but you know,
to keep learning more about what you
see in the future and how someone in my
position who is currently
in public leadership,
obviously I'm running now for president,
uh,
can be much more supportive in creating
the circumstances that enable not only
Google and people like
those of you who work here,
but so many millions of more around
our own country and around the world,
make that better future.
So this is exciting for
me and I appreciate the
opportunity to be here and, uh,
look forward to the
conversation with Eric. So,
so was her first question
was a Google earth question.
So we have a senator here
who's paying attention.
When I think about the political
campaign that you're now embarking on,
which I think is as many ways a physical
marathon having seen people do it
before.
What I,
what I don't like about the way it's
covered is everybody focuses on the past.
And my view is that what
this really is is an,
and it's an extended job interview between
the citizenry hiring you to be their
president. So, so I think a,
a good starting question is let's
talk about the future as you see it.
Um, and uh, critics would say, uh,
and I think with some
validity that Iraq is a mess,
that our global positioning
as a country is a mess.
That we have deficits before
us that are larger than we can,
that we've ever foreseen with
no obvious solution site.
And the criticism was go on and on.
Take us through the future as you see it.
Tell us why things will be better or
different with your insights and your view
and your ability to put people together.
That's a great,
great question.
And I want you all to imagine with me,
um,
what our country will be like in 10 years,
which will be the end of my second term,
uh,
or
the alternative that we just
keep going the way we are,
which I think would be really,
uh,
so counter to who we
should be as Americans.
Every time anybody runs for office,
they say that this is the
most important election.
And I think every election is important,
which is why I hope that each and every
one of you will take that responsibility
seriously now and in the future.
But I really do think this is a defining
moment election because we have so much
unfinished business at home and
abroad and we have a choice to make.
You know,
no matter how successful you are as an
individual or how successful you are as a
company,
there are certain things that we can only
do together through the instrument of
our government.
So I hope that the future
holds not just the promise,
but the reality of universal health care
coverage that provides high quality,
affordable health care
for every single American.
And I think Google has a real role to
play in helping us make that happen.
So it's not just what I see.
It's what I hope you see as well.
I hope the future holds that we have
an energy system that is no longer
dependent upon fossil fuels,
imported from regimes around the world,
but that instead we have figured out how
best to incentivize the private sector
to make investments that will to clean
green energy becoming dominant in our
nation, which will be good for the
economy, good for the environment,
and good for our security.
I hope the future holds that within
10 years we will have made progress on
global climate change. We're
no longer denying it. We have,
I hope that an over the bump of people
saying we can't do it because it will
wreck our account,
our economy,
but instead we see what needs to
happen will be good for the planet,
but it also can be good for the economy.
You know,
when President Bush took us out of Kyoto,
Prime Minister Blair took Great Britain
in and they created tens of thousands of
new jobs in trying to figure out how to
decrease greenhouse gas emissions and
clean up the environment.
I hope that the future will
see an education system
that starts with preschool
opportunities for kids who need some
extra help so they can enter school ready
to learn that we'll have
many more qualified teachers,
particularly in math and science and other
shortage areas and a culture starting
with the family.
But going beyond that really values
education in America and creates a feeling
among our citizenry that it's important.
I was telling Eric and Larry and Sergei
and others a story about how when I was
in fifth grade and Sputnik was sent up,
I don't have to tell you what Sputnik,
you'll need to tell him what will
make me feel very all very all to do.
I'm sorry.
Well, I can't, uh, you'll
have to look it up on Google.
But,
but when it went up
and it was,
you know,
a direct threat to America's primacy
in science and technology and space
exploration from the Soviet Union,
the whole country was galvanized.
You know,
I remember conversations about it over
the dinner table and I remember my fifth
grade teacher coming in and saying,
children,
the president wants you
to study math and science.
I personally thought the president,
President Eisenhower had called
Mrs Brows and 12th how us,
but
it, it had a feeling that we were all in
this together. Out of that came Darpa,
out of that came the space programs so
much else that galvanized your parents or
grandparents generation to be part
of something bigger than themselves.
It had enormous spinoff for the creation
of wealth and new jobs and increase in
our gross domestic product because we
set some goals partly in reaction to what
others were doing, but also because
it's part of the American spirit.
So in all of these areas,
what I see if we make the right decisions,
both through our government and in our
private sector and on an individual,
because there's a role for each person
to play and doing more to achieve this
better future. And of course I
see a future where once again,
United States is respected
around the world,
that our moral authority and
our leadership is helping
to solve problems and
recognizes that we will do
better if we work together,
that we create alliances
and relationships.
So 10 years is a long
time and individual life,
but it's not a long time
in the life of a country.
If we start down this path to renew
the promise of America at home and to
restore respect for us abroad,
then in 10 years we will be more
competitive. We will be better position,
we will have begun to deal with a lot
of the problems that left untended will
undermine our standard of living,
our quality of life,
and make the world a more dangerous place.
So we have two visions stay where we are
refused to deal with the problems that
we have. Refused to find ways to bring
people together to create new incentives,
to set goals or do what we're
best at doing. You know,
put our minds to work,
unleash our entrepreneurial energy,
create the framework to address these
problems and call our citizens again,
you know,
to make a contribution to putting us back
on the right path to a better future.
Think about what you
have chosen to embark on.
The world is different now
politically in terms of the,
the way the primary is work and so forth.
Can you take us a little bit through what
it's going to take in these first two
years? How will it play out? What
expectations should we have? Um,
where will you be? How will
we see you? Right. Well,
um,
this is,
uh,
a marathon and it's starting a lot
earlier than it ever has before.
But those of you who have an interest
or who have followed American, uh, uh,
political campaigns, uh, before I,
you'll probably recall that,
uh,
we didn't have this much
intensity or energy this early,
uh, in previous election cycles. In fact,
when my husband first ran for president,
he did not announce he would
run until October of 1991.
And then,
you know,
it was a sprint through the primaries
and then obviously the general election.
So the way this is set up now is there
are a couple of states that have early
contests.
You've got the caucuses in Iowa first,
then caucuses in Nevada
as currently scheduled,
then a primary election in New Hampshire,
and then a primary election
in South Carolina. Now,
if that was all that was going on,
it would be demanding but manageable.
But a lot of the big states have decided
that they don't want to be on the
sidelines.
They want to be in the mix.
And that means that they're moving
their dates up. So for example,
California now intends to move up to be,
you know,
within a week of South Carolina
on February 5th, Florida.
Wants to move up to the same day, South
Carolina. And then you've got, you know,
other states like New Jersey and Texas
and maybe even New York. So in effect,
Eric,
we're going to be running one national
campaign for the primary and then another
national campaign for the
general election. And you know,
I'm just going to be, is this vitamin
water? I'm going to be drinking,
I'm going to be drinking a lot of
vitamin water. I'm going to try to, um,
you know,
run a campaign that keeps the focus on
what I want to do on the issues that
people talk to me about.
Because as I travel around the country,
a lot of the issues I mentioned
in addition of course to
Iraq and Iran and some
of the others that are really
on the front pages and,
and deeply concerning to people,
uh,
are what everybody wants to talk about
and what I would do as president. Uh,
and I hope that, uh, we can
get people more involved.
I think one of the reasons the campaign
has started so early this year is there
a lot of people, not just Democrats,
but independents, Republicans,
people who before were never
politically affiliated,
which I'm finding more and more coming
to events for me who just don't want to
think about the next two years.
They want to leap over the fact that we
have our current occupant in the White
House and get to the 2008 election.
So there's all this pent
up energy to get out there,
change the future.
Several Googlers sent in questions about,
um,
abuse of executive power up.
Okay.
I
think they were referring to a different,
one of the things that,
that you did that was very interesting
was how you transitioned from first lady
to senator.
And it notable because it was highly
criticized and notable also because it was
extraordinarily successful.
And it's a very interesting story in my
view of transformation of yourself and
how you worked at. And I'm acutely
aware of the fact that the burden,
the burden on women in, in high
places is even tougher in many ways.
The standards seem to be higher.
The criticisms are harsher in many ways
for reasons I don't understand. Uh,
and maybe, maybe you do, maybe
you don't, you live this,
you live this transition from first
lady to senator. How did you do it?
How did you become a senator in New York?
How did you make things
successful in New York? Uh,
especially in the red parts as
opposed to the red and the blue parts?
It's a great question.
You know, um, well, well,
one thing and I,
and I appreciate your saying that it is
still challenging for women because I
think that is the case.
Although we've certainly made a tremendous
amount of progress and much more to
come.
But I was lucky when I was growing up,
I had the same expectations for me and my,
my brother's in my family,
uh, from my parents. You know,
there was no difference in,
uh, that wasn't the case
with a lot of my girlfriends.
It may seem like ancient history,
but you know,
there were scholarships I couldn't get,
there was schools I couldn't go to.
There were jobs that really were not open
to women, uh, when I was a young girl,
but my parents believed in education
and gave me the opportunities to really
develop self confidence and belief that
I could do what I set my mind to doing.
And I also worked a lot all
during my growing up years.
I had my first job when I was 13,
um,
at a little park where I supervise kids.
And I just always had a
lot of opportunities to get
out into the world to sort
of test myself and kind of
see what the reaction was.
And I played sports not well,
but I did play sports in
those days and I loved that.
And it was competitive and you know,
you played with boys and
you had to play the game.
And so I learned a lot about, you know,
how to present myself and how to compete.
And obviously when I graduated from
college, I decided to go to law school,
which was still somewhat
unusual for women, uh,
and had a great experience and then
went to work and had a lot of different,
uh,
jobs all the way up until I quit
working when bill became president.
So I had always worked.
I worked and I was a working mother and
I know the challenges of being, you know,
a parent with family responsibilities.
So when bill became president,
um,
I transitioned into a full time volunteer,
which was something new for me because
I had never been a full time volunteer
and I loved volunteering.
But this became, you know,
the role that I had and it
was a great eight years,
but it was different
from the rest of my life,
particularly my working life.
So in a funny way,
running for and serving as senator was
getting back more to having the kind of
job that I always had had.
And when I started to run for the Senate,
it seemed like such a,
you know,
long shot and,
and hard to believe that I
could make the transition.
But I was very comfortable doing
it because I liked campaigning.
I love policy. I think it
really matters, you know,
what decisions made and how
they affect people's lives.
So as I traveled around
the state of New York,
I made it very clear that I wanted
to represent the entire state.
And is Eric says,
you know,
a lot of people look at California
or look at New York and say, well,
everybody's one kind of person.
Well, how absurd that is.
Everybody knows the diversity in
California and the diversity in New York.
So as I traveled, I visited a lot of
places that didn't vote for Democrats.
They had never elected a woman
statewide to anything and in our state.
So I had, uh, you know,
pretty significant hurdle to overcome,
to prove myself, to stand on my
own feet, to make my own case.
And I'm very grateful that the people
of New York gave me the chance to serve.
And when I got to the Senate, a lot of
people didn't know what to expect. Um,
there was some kind of funny thing said,
one of the leaders on the other side
of the aisle after I was elected said,
well maybe lightning will strike
and she won't come after all.
So I knew that I had a lot to prove
and I did what I've always done,
which is just to work really hard,
learn as much as I could and find
ways to reach across the party divide,
which I think can be so destructive
if it's not bridged. You know, we,
we stand on the opposite sides and we've
got all these problems and instead of
working to bring people together
to solve them, you know,
people just retreat and
kind of talk to themselves.
So I worked with a lot of people who were,
you know,
not exactly favorable to me during the
time that a bill was in the White House.
But you know,
I've found common ground with
them and I find the job, you know,
very rewarding because you get to really
look for ways on a very individual
level to help somebody as well as
the more macro level. You know,
for me,
you know,
helping a child get healthcare who's
insurance company has denied his parents,
uh,
the right to get the treatment that
their doctors say he needs is incredibly
important.
And it kind of keeps me going because
sometimes the bar on the bureaucracy and
the political back and forth prevents
positive things from happening.
But if you can even help one person,
you know,
it feels like it's worthwhile. And
then I've been able to, you know,
do some good legislation and,
and work things through, uh,
to try to make a difference.
And obviously I'm very gratified that
people reelected me in this last election
was 67% of the vote and from a lot of
people and a lot of areas of the state
don't usually vote for Democrats don't
think they ever would have voted for me.
Um, so I think it's just like
anything else. I mean, you,
you really set your goals,
you work hard to achieve them,
and you try to bring more people in
to share credit and be part of moving
forward together to, you know, get to
those goals. That's what matters to me.
Obviously, you know, you
sometimes you can't make it,
but in general it's a very rewarding
way to, you know, to work. And I,
I'm glad that I was able
to make the transition and
obviously now I'm looking to
make another transition
based on everything I've done
my entire life and all of
the preparation and experience and
qualifications that I bring to this
presidential campaign. So, so we had a,
uh,
a meeting with a number of leaders in
Silicon Valley a few minutes ago and a lot
of the conversation was about your
view of and the energy and environment.
And in your comments today with us,
you indicated that's a major area along
with education in a couple of others
with this audience and
people who were really,
people just really aren't going to do it.
Sketch out how you would like it to
play out the role of private sector.
Uh, the opportunity before us,
you cited a very interesting,
interesting statistic for
example about California.
The California has per capita energy use
has not caught up, right? Right. So again,
I'm looking at it from
policy policies perspective.
Take us through why we are where we
are as a nation and then how would you
change or how would you see it changing?
Well, that's a, that's a really
long conversation. But let
me try to, you know, just,
um, it, because I know many of
you are interested in, you know,
what we're going to do with energy
and what we're going to do with the
environment.
And they really are one in the same.
You can't separate out trying
to deal with the environment,
particularly climate change
without dealing with how
we generate energy and how
we use it.
And as I look at where we are today,
um, we've had a lot of missed
opportunities going back, you know,
more than I'm 35 years.
Uh,
we had some effort that nationally made
a little progress in the mid to late
seventies and trying to get people to
focus on raising gas mileage of our cars
to looking for alternative fuel
sources. Then the, you know,
fossil fuels that we have relied on in
incentivizing conservation and energy
efficiency. But when, uh,
President Reagan took office in 1981,
he and the Republican Congress dismantle
what was the beginnings of a kind of
energy policy that would change
how we thought about energy,
incentivize different
approaches. California, however,
maintained its emphasis on
conservation and efficiency.
So we're California is today is that
despite an explosive growth in energy
usage,
particularly here in Silicon Valley,
electricity usage has remained flat
in terms of per capita usage here in
California in the rest of
the country has gone up 50%.
So when somebody in another state kind
of buys in to what is the Republican
White House line about how we
can't do anything about energy,
and certainly we can't do anything about
climate change without wrecking our
economy. I say, well, isn't
that interesting? Look at
what California has done.
We would be further along if we had
kept the conservation and efficiency
measures that California cap and now
we've got to sort of reinvent them
nationally.
But California sets a good example.
This has to be a public
private partnership and it
has to be at all levels of
public government,
federal, state, and local.
At the federal level.
We do need a much broader energy policy
that shifts our subsidies and incentives
away from,
you know,
gas and oil into alternatives that
looks for cleaner ways to deliver coal,
for example,
that really provides a much greater
support for biofuels and biodiesel that
tries to get, get gas
mileage up that, you know,
looks at how we can use production
tax credits even more for, you know,
wind and solar and
geothermal and all the rest.
But that has to be translated down
so that it's state and local levels.
Their support for these changes.
You know,
when we were talking in the
earlier conversation, um,
Sergei and Larry were talking about how
Google had decided to put more solar
panels here, but there was
so many obstacles at the
local level about, you know,
what you had to do to get that
done and get them installed.
So it's not just what
happens at the federal level.
We have to change the attitude
of government up and down
the scale to really be
committed to this new energy future.
And then the private sector I think
can make a lot of money in new forms of
energy and there's a lot of
investment that is now going on,
very much centered here in silicon valley.
So if we have the right messages and
incentives coming from Washington,
if we have capital that is now ready to
invest in new technologies and let's bet
on a bunch of them and not
preordained what may or may not work,
then the missing piece is the individual.
You know,
what will the individual do? I
mean, will the individual, namely,
all of us buy into this new energy future,
you know,
will we buy the car with
the higher gas mileage?
Will we buy the house with those
funny blue solar panels on top?
We'll we want the wind turbine on
the mountain that we look out at.
Will we conserve and by the
energy efficient appliances,
I'm betting we will if we
create this, this group. Well,
and you are trendsetters. And
I mean that seriously. I mean,
we have to get this to be
something everybody does
because if we're not part of
the solution,
then truly we are,
part of the problem is the old cliche
goes and at the end of the day we have to
have millions,
hundreds of millions of decisions that
are made every single day to choose clean
green energy.
And then we also have to create
the conditions for clean,
green power generation.
Uh,
and we have to both through carrots and
sticks bring that about. But you know,
I think the time has come and
I'm hoping that, um, you know,
on Sunday night,
Al Gore wins the Oscar for inconvenient
truth and that'll give us another one
booth in the right direction.
When I look at the rock situation,
I see a mass,
as I said in my personal view is that one,
it's a civil war.
And to adding or deleting troops, neither
scenario seems like a good scenario.
Whoa.
Go looking, looking
forward, looking forward,
not looking backward. Looking
forward. What should we do?
Uh,
maybe President Bush,
we'll leave this issue to his successor,
in which case it's probably
the first thing on the desk,
right when you get there.
Right?
Well, actually he has said several times
he's going to leave it to his successor,
which I think is the height of your
responsibility. This is his war.
He should extricate us from it
before he leaves. But if he,
it continues down the path he has chosen,
it is likely to be on the desk.
That is exactly right. Well, what
would we or should we do going forward?
What if we could persuade the president,
uh,
to change course would we want him to
do well? Number one, no escalation.
Stop the troop escalation.
Do not send thousands of more
combat troops and thousands
more support troops to
try to intervene in a
multi-sided sectarian civil war.
It is hard to know who you're shooting
at and who is shooting at you.
I have legislation to the effect that we
should cap the number of troops so that
it would be illegal for the
president to send additional troops.
At the very least,
we should make it illegal for the
president to send any young American in
uniform and to combat with all all of the
equipment and training he or she needs
to protect themselves
and their fellow soldiers.
We also need to make it clear to the Iraqi
government that the days of the check
or over, we're not going to continue
to fund their security forces and their
reconstruction unless they do what is
necessary to begin to put in place a
political solution.
We know what the pieces of it are.
As difficult as it might be.
Number one,
there has to be a decision made about how
to allocate oil revenues in a fair and
equitable manner.
Something that I have pushed for since
summer of Oh three when I said do an oil
trust and I had bipartisan
support for it in the Senate,
we couldn't get it frankly past
the vice president's office.
We also need to get the Iraqis to reverse
their deep bath application to amend
their constitution and to begin to
try to figure out how to isolate the
extremists on both sides of
this sectarian civil war.
We also should convene an international
conference where the neighbors in the
region are put on the spot about what
they will do to help stabilize the rock.
We, we unfortunately, are confronted
with the president's approach,
which is we don't talk to bad people
and I think that is the most absurd
diplomatic position to take.
You don't make peace with your friends,
you don't even do business with
your friends a lot of the time.
You have to deal with people
whose worldview is different,
whose interests are sometimes
antithetical to your own.
During the Cold War where the Soviet
Union had thousands of missiles pointed at
us and where their leaders
repeatedly said they would bury us,
are Republican and Democratic presidents
always talk to them and it was a very
smart thing to do.
We actually could make some progress,
we could get better intelligence,
we could figure out how to leverage
what we needed against them and we could
send a message behind the iron curtain
that people in the United States cared
about the future of people who were
under totalitarian communist rule.
We need to be talking to Iran,
we need to be talking to Syria.
We need to be talking to our
adversaries and failing to do so.
Postpones any effort we can realistically
have of trying to manage these
difficult situations.
So there is a lot we could
start doing right now, Eric,
but we're locked into unfortunately a
situation where the president believes
he's right.
I argue it's against reality,
but he believes it's right and he seems
impervious to evidence or argument or
reason.
And is determined to pursue this policy
and the only way we can legally reign
him in is if we get 60 votes
in the senate. Why is that?
Because the house has different rules
and Nancy Polosi is doing a great job as
speaker and she pushed through
a strong resolution of disapproval of
the president's policy in the Senate.
The rules are different.
It's a kind of um, you know,
balance that our founders set up.
The Senate is more difficult
to get things through.
You've got to in effect get 60 votes
for anything controversial because
otherwise a minority can dig his heels
in and prevent anything from happening.
Well,
last week we got 56 votes,
a strong bipartisan majority against
the president's escalation policy,
but we didn't get 60 so we have to keep
the pressure on Republican senators to
join with us, to try to rein
him in. I hope we can do that.
That's what we're trying very hard to do.
I'm not giving up on doing it,
but if at the end of
this president's term,
he has not extricated us from Iraq,
I will because I believe
it's so important.
It has to be the first item on the desk.
When you walk into the Oval Office,
the Senate senator,
Senator Clemens,
you're, you're, you're late
for your next appointment.
But I have to ask you one unfair question.
We have all of the people
who make Google of success.
You are a Google user.
You have a vision of the world.
What would you have us do
well?
What are the things that
Google can help your vision,
right to happen? Oh, I have
some very specific ideas.
You have some bug reports and
well,
keep Google earth going.
Maybe that'll change some more minds.
That's obviously important.
You know,
the problems and the opportunities
that I started out talking about.
I think all of you who work at Google
and the company collectively can really
help us address them.
As Eric was showing me around,
we stopped at, uh, one of the offices
where the health team was working.
We cannot get to universal healthcare
coverage unless we have a much better
information base that is very
reliable that people can turn to,
to make decisions on their own, to be
empowered as consumers of healthcare.
And that is something I know you're
working on and we really need you to be
aggressively pursuing that.
We also need more information technology.
Someone's decided to play the piano while
you're eating. I'm sorry. It is Google.
Yeah. You know, we do need
more information technology
generally in health care.
Um, I don't know how many of
you been to the doctor recently,
but if you bought gone to a new doctor,
they probably took a new history on paper.
They probably don't have electronic
medical records. If you go to visit,
say in New York and you have
an accident or you get sick,
you need to go to the doctor,
they'll have to do it all over again
because they probably can't transfer what
you have at your doctor here to
where they are. The health sector,
which uses over 16 cents out of every
dollar we spend in America is woefully
deficient in information technology.
Any way you can help us move our health
sector into the 21st century will help
us to get a base of information on which
we can make better decisions to provide
healthcare to everybody. When it
comes to energy or the environment,
there's a lot of entrepreneurial
genius in this room.
Anything that we can do to incentivize
people to make better investments or to
make better personal decisions by
going to Google or getting new ways of
communicating through Google or
new ideas. Please do. And finally,
you know,
with respect to education,
I really wish we could figure out how
to do much more online education more
effectively in more places where kids are
not being given a fair chance to get a
first class education.
Our schools are still stuck in
a 20th century industrial model.
They're open certain hours,
which is not very family friendly
for a lot of working parents.
The technology that's available,
I'm not talking about the best
schools which are terrific,
but in general the technology that's
available is not really, you know,
used to the utmost to further
the educational experience
of whoever the student
is.
And we need much more intensive
opportunities across the
online world so that if
you're in a school where you don't have
maybe the best math curriculum but you
have an aptitude for it,
what can you do here at Google to help
capture the imagination of that young boy
or girl so that they stay with math and
science so that they help contribute to
what we need to do to transform our
economy and be competitive globally.
And I guess really the last thing I would
say about what you can do is, you know,
Google links the world
and we need a lot more understanding
and communication among all of us.
And particularly we need to reassert
America's willingness to actually listen
to other people that we want to be part
of an ongoing conversation globally.
That we want to send a message to
people around the world that, you know,
America is back,
that we care about you that were
interested in helping solve your problems,
were not self centered and you know,
finger pointing and line drawing the
way we've appeared the last six years.
Because every challenge we face
globally can only be addressed if we're
interconnected and that we
recognize our interdependence.
And Google is a great metaphor for that.
So the more we can do it,
the better off we'll be.
And I thank you for everything you
are doing and will do for the future.
Thank you.
I have,
I have only one request of the senator.
I have hours of more interesting questions
and I'm sure you have hours and we're
seeing answers, so we want
you to come back, okay?
Okay. Hi. Thank you for
coming. Thank you very much.